HAILEE STEINFELD
In our new series Hawkeye, Clint Barton
may have met his equal with
his new teammate, Kate Bishop.
JEREMY RENNER
That's debatable. But right now we're
going to see who's the better
marksman, me or Hailee.
HAILEE STEINFELD
You're going down, Renner.
JEREMY RENNER
We'll see about that.
- Just hit a balloon.
- Just shush.
- Boom! I'll take it.
- Got it, nice.
- Shoot.
- Well, you're consistent.
HAILEE STEINFELD
Thank you, go on.
Ah! No! I swear...
I- this is a joke. This is rigged.
Ha! It's not, I'm
just kidding. Woo!
JEREMY RENNER
You got it.
- Ohhhh!
- Yeah!
HAILEE STEINFELD
Yeah, baby!
Cornhole.
JEREMY RENNER
Pizza Dog cornhole.
HAILEE STEINFELD
Alright.
- Nice.
- Boom.
- Close. Doh! Sorry.
- Ahhh... That was good defense though.
HAILEE STEINFELD
[Laughing]
- [Laughing]
- What's next?
[Laughter]
- Ohhh-ho! There it is.
- Ohhh!
JEREMY RENNER
The action is just tremendous... Oh, Thanos!
HAILEE STEINFELD
You weren't even looking!
[Laughter]
- Hey!
- There you go!
HAILEE STEINFELD
Oh! And I still missed it! Grrrr!
[Laughing]
HAILEE STEINFELD
Well, that was fun!
JEREMY RENNER
More fun than shooting exploding arrows?
HAILEE STEINFELD
No, of course not,
nothing's more fun than that.